we're on problem 53 it says tony is
solving this equation by completing the
square ax squared plus bx plus c is
equal to zero where a is greater than
zero so this is just a traditional
quadratic right here and let's see what
they did let's see first he subtracted c
from both sides
and you've got ax squared plus bx
is equal to minus c okay that's fair
enough
and then let's see let's see divided
both sides by a
right that's fair enough you got minus
the array which step should be step
three in the solution so he's completing
the square so
essentially he wants
this to become a perfect square so let's
see how we can do that
so we have x squared
plus b
over a
x
is and i'm going to leave a little space
here is equal to
minus c over a
so for this to be a perfect square we
have to add something here we have to
add a number and we learned from several
videos in the past and we kind of pseudo
proved and actually have several videos
where i i do solely on completing the
square you essentially have to add
whatever number this is add half of it
squared and if that doesn't make sense
to you watch the khan academy video on
completing the square but what is half
of b over a
well it's b over 2a right
now what's b over so
one half times b over a
is equal to b over 2a
and then we want to add this squared so
let's add that to both sides of this
equation so we're left with
x squared
plus b over ax and we want to add this
squared plus
b
over 2a
squared
is equal to
minus c over a anything you add to one
side of the equation you have to add to
the other so we have to add that to both
sides plus b over 2 a
squared
and let's see what if we've solved the
problem so far what they want x
b over 2 right this is exactly what we
did x squared plus b over a plus b over
2a squared and add it to both sides
equation so d is the right answer now if
you find that a little confusing or if
it wasn't intuitive for you i don't want
you to memorize the steps watch the khan
academy video on completing the square
next problem 56 no 54.
all right this is another one that
should be cut and pasted
all right four steps to derive the
quadratic formula from below i said in
previous videos that
you can derive the quadratic formula by
completing the square and we actually do
that in another video i don't want to
give too much of a plug for other videos
but let's see what they want to do what
is the correct order of these steps so
the first thing you want to start off
with is just like a quad just a
quadratic equation
and this one
is the first step
right this is where we started off with
in the last problem
then what you want to do is add half of
this squared to both sides so b over
2a squared you want to add to both sides
and that's what they did here so our
order is 1
and then you want to do 4
right that's what we did in the last
problem
we did 4
and then from here you know that this
expression right here is going to be
equal to
x plus b over 2a squared and once again
watch the completing the squared video
if that didn't make sense but the whole
reason why you added this here so that
you know that okay what two numbers when
i multiply them equal b over 2a squared
and when i add them equal b over a well
it's obviously b over 2a right if you
add it twice you're going to get b over
a if you squared you're going to get
this whole expression so you say oh this
is just x plus b over 2a squared and you
get that there
and then is equal to
and then they just simplify this
fraction they found a common denominator
and all the rest and so the next step is
step two and then all you have left is
step three and you've pretty much
derived the quadratic equation so 1 4 2
3
1 4 2 3 that's choice a
problem 55
which of the solutions okay so then i'll
write i'll put all the choices down
so which is one of the solutions to the
equation so immediately when you see all
the choices they have these square roots
and all of that this isn't something
that you would factor you would use a
quadratic equation here so let's do that
so the quadratic equation
is
so this is ax squared a x squared
plus b x plus c is equal to zero the
quadratic equation is
minus b well they do it lowercase plus
or minus the square root of b squared
minus 4ac
all of that over 2a and this is just
derived from completing the square with
this but we do that in another video
and so let's substitute it in what is b
b is minus one right so minus minus one
that's a positive one
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus one squared is one
minus 4
times a a is 2
times 2
times c
c is minus 4
so times minus 4
minus 4 all of that over 2a a is 2 so 2
times a is 4. so that becomes 1
1 plus or minus the square root
so we have a 1 so minus 4 times a 2
times a minus 4. so those
that's the same thing as a plus 4 times
2 times a plus 4 right let's just take
that minus out
so it's plus and then there's no minus
here right so let's see 4 times 2 is 8
times 4 is 32 plus 1 is 33
33 all of that over
4.
see we're not quite there yet well they
say which is one of the solutions to the
equation
so let's see
if we wanted to simplify
this out of oh this was right here right
because we have 1 plus or minus the
square root of 33 over 4 well they wrote
just one of them they wrote just the
plus
so c is one of the solutions the other
one would have been if you had a minus
sign here
anyway next problem
56.
56 this is another one need to cut and
paste
says which statement best explains why
there is no real solution to the
quadratic equation
okay
so i already have a a guess of why this
won't have a solution but in general you
know
let's write the quadratic equation
before even looking at this problem
let's get an intuition it's negative b
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4
a c
all of that over 2a
my question is to use when does this not
make any sense
well you know this will work for any b
any 2a but when does a square root sign
really fall apart at least when we're
dealing with real numbers and that's a
clue is well it's when when you have a
negative number under here right if this
if you end up with a negative number on
the square root sign at least if we
haven't learned imaginary numbers yet
you don't know what to do you you
there's no real solution to the
quadratic equation so if b squared
minus 4ac
is less than 0 you're in trouble there's
no real solution right you can't take a
square root of a negative sign if you're
dealing with real numbers
so that's probably going to be the
problem here so let's see what b squared
minus 4ac is you have b is 1 so 1
minus 4
times a
a is 2
2 times c is 7.
and sure enough 1 times 4 times 2 times
7 is going to be less than 0.
so let's let's see what they have here
right the value of 1 squared all right
it's b squared is yeah well 1 squared
same thing as 1. 1 squared minus 4 times
2 times 7 sure enough is negative so
that's why we don't have a real solution
to this equation
next problem i'm actually out of space
let me
all right
okay they want another solution set to
this quadratic equation i'll just
copy and paste the
so that's essentially the the set of the
x's that satisfy this equation they
don't want
and obviously for any x that you put in
this the left-hand side is going to be
equal to zero so what x's are valid and
they just want us to apply the quadratic
equation so we've written it a couple of
times but let's just do it straight up
so it's negative b b is 2 right so it's
negative 2
plus or minus the square root of b
squared well that's 2 squared
minus 4
times a
a is 8
times c
which is one
all of that over two times a so two
times eight
which is equal to minus two plus or
minus the square root
of
four
4 let's see
4. did i write this down
negative b
negative b plus or minus square root of
b squared
b squared
minus 4
times a times c right so you get 4
minus
32
that's why i was double checking to see
if i did this right because i'm going to
get a negative number here all of that
over 16.
and so we're going to end up with the
same conundrum we added the last i mean
4 minus 32 we're going to end up with
minus 2 plus or minus the square root of
minus 28
over 16.
and if we're dealing with real numbers i
mean there's there's no real solution
here and at first i was worried i
thought i made a careless mistake or
there was an error in the problem but
then i look at the choices and
they have choice d and i'll copy and
paste choice d here
choice d no real solution so that's the
answer because you can't take a square
root of the negative number and stay in
the real number in the in the set of
real numbers
let's see do you have time for another
one i'm over the 10 minutes
i'll wait for the next video see you
soon